hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
pharmacogenetics and psychology
presented by dr. Daniel Mueller now head
of the pharmacogenetics research clinic
at the Campbell family mental health
research institute at CAMH an associate
professor in the department of
psychiatry at the university of torah i
am xavier gutierrez of lab routes and i
will be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
and type the questions into the
drop-down box that appear on the screen
what answers many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click on the
help desk button located and the
promotion of board at the bottom and or
center of your screen or use the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
on the on the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Muller will now
turn the presentation over to him
hello thank you very much for this nice
introduction my name is dr. Mueller I am
stop psychiatrist at the Centre for
Addiction and Mental Health in Toronto
we are Canada's largest mental health
centre I'm a professor at the department
psychiatry and have a secondary
appointment with the pharmacology and
toxicology department my area of
research over the past two decades has
been to improve medication treatment in
psychiatry by using genetic information
which is commonly referred to as
pharmacogenetics and I would like to
briefly talk about the complexities of
psychiatry and perhaps also why we have
difficulties in finding the right
medications and why genetics can
hopefully help us to improve that
considerably in order to give the best
treatment to our patients if we look at
psychiatry and I'm trying to here we go
I'm trying to show you some of the
common psychiatric conditions that epic
hide risk can and will encounter
typically during during their work you
can see quite a number of conditions
here listed by the typically used dsm-5
criteria and you can see that it
involves neurodevelopmental disorder for
example then we have all the spectrum of
psychotic disorders in schizophrenia we
have bipolar disorders depressive
disorders anxiety disorders OCD and many
many more and I was myself surprised my
must sail when I was a meds when I was
in med school and when I was a student I
really believed that psychiatry is a
niche area where most people will not
get you know will not have to deal with
and it's it's a rather you know rather
uncommon situation but that definitely
is not true
people just don't talk about it there is
a lot of stigma and those people are
really severely ill obviously are
treated in hospitals and anywhere else
and you just don't see them as much
however it has been it has been
estimated that about one third of the
population so that's one out of three
will at some point in their lives
encounter of psychiatric condition and
if you think about that and even if it's
only 20% maybe if you feel really strict
on your criterias that means one out of
five and that means that basically every
family has at least one someone affected
every family including second-degree
relatives if you wish as at least one
affected by statistics so that means
everyone actually in in in our society
is likely to interact even on our family
basis but also maybe at work and
anywhere else to patients or to people
who suffer from mental disorder so it is
very common actually and that's what we
kept in mind because it also tell it it
also reflects the high prescription rate
of psychiatric medications in the
community and for example in Canada just
so a recent statistics where the
medication which is mostly prescribed to
women number one are antidepressants and
were very surprised to see that myself I
wouldn't believe that but apparently
that's how it is so and in certain ways
psychiatric conditions are spectrums
it's not always again you know easy to
draw a line who has treatable symptoms
or not we still we still you know we
still can do a much better job certainly
and also understanding psychiatry
conditions and and defining them and
finding perhaps new ways of diagnostics
like biomarkers and so on but again
today this is all about treatment and
last not least we also have complexities
in terms of
what we call personality disorders or
some sorry personality disorders which
believe it or not it might be also you
know often require medication treatment
and you know among them are things like
borderline personality disorders
schizoid personality disorders and
whatnot
these are milder if you wish sometimes
sometimes they can be a bit milder
condition than the full disorder but
they sometimes can also be by themselves
highly problematic and associated with
with lots of self-harm and so on and
here sometimes again we cannot even
though these conditions are typically
best treated with psychological
interventions psychotherapy and so on
we sometimes cannot avoid using
medications in order to alleviate some
of the most acute symptoms however what
are these medications about and it's
been now known for some time for decades
that our brain has two major
neurotransmitters and one of those are
the dopamine pathways and the other one
are the serotonin pathways and they do a
lot of things dopamine and serotonin
sometimes we get simplistic ideas about
them you know dopamine has been the
pleasure hormone and and serotonin being
about happiness and so on it is a bit
more complex than that but however we
can certainly see that most of the
medications which are prescribed
particularly for psychotic disorders
which would be antipsychotics or
depression and anxieties which would be
antidepressants both of them typically
target broadly and either dopamine
pathways or certain pathways and by
doing so they often achieve you know you
well you can often see that they achieve
some good results in terms of the
symptoms that that patients are
complaining about however it should be
still seen as a kind of broad
intervention itself
a bit like you know in in Physiology
it's when you when you really don't know
for example what the germ might be you
give a you know you give one of these
broads antibiotics and you basically
kill a bit everything and and you will
also hit then you know that of course
you will likely hit also the germs the
bacteria that you would like to hit
because they are they're causing the
problems but it's a little bit similar
to that so with these medications we're
still a bit bulldozing in a certain way
these pathways which again sometimes
then also cause side effects which we
which we don't like and patients
certainly would like at all and you have
to balance that often you have to really
balance what is the lesser evil now here
to choose medications or to not use
medications and how to use them and how
to you know how to do this with with you
know the least side effects and and the
good thing is newer medications are much
more selective than older medications
and newer medications often are much
better tolerated and also come with less
side effects and so on however they
still mostly target these two pathways
particularly is medication I'm going to
talk about today which aren't in
presence and I'm psychotics mostly
target either or these two pathways and
and and that is good in a certain way
that we have the really cases but again
we have not been successful even though
these these passwords have been known
for decades now we have been at least
little successful let's say to target
psychiatric centers by by finding how to
how to be perhaps more selective and
perhaps even target other pathways which
might also be important there has been a
lot of research done unfortunately
however because of the complexities of
the brain because of the heterogeneity
of symptoms and so on were unfortunately
not there yet to to offer you know
really advanced medications and that's
where we will then have to
learn again to the shelves that we have
today and see how we can do the best or
treatment how we can how we can select
and and basically find the best
treatment by the medication that we
currently have and I usually start like
to start my presentations with a famous
quote from Sir William Osler who was a
Canadian physician and who was the first
who published an encyclopedia about all
medical conditions and treatments back
in the 19th century anyone said if it
were not for the great variability among
individuals medicine might be assigned
and not an art that's a bit surprising
perhaps because we all believe of course
that our treatments are very much based
on science and research and on data on
evidence-based medicine and so on but
the reality often shows that no two
patients are alike and even though they
present maybe with the same symptoms you
would think they made then benefit from
the same treatment but that is not often
the case you have to basically become a
little bit creative a little bit you
know ready to to see variations and to
see one patients improving without side
effects the next patients might improve
but has side effects doesn't want to
take the medication and then patients
who might not even improve and have only
side effects and then patients who where
nothing really happens even after six
weeks of let's say a 10 person treatment
so here you have to become a bit
creative you have to you have to look
into sometimes in to really you know
combining perhaps medication augmenting
medications with other agents and so on
and that that is complex that is that is
difficult again because you never know
the outcome upfront and of course it
makes it a bit look like a trial and
error approach even though I believe we
should be careful by saying trial and
error all the time but definitely it is
a bit like you become a little creative
and and and you know you cannot always
find answers in the books
however what is variation what are they
coming from why do people show variation
and do we know nothing about it
or do we know something about it and if
we look at you know variability in
medication outcome we know at least a
few things already which are definitely
important in dosing in terms of side
effect that we might see and so on and
that is certainly age so we would not
treat a child similar to let's say in
order adult we know that gender matters
in terms of dosing in terms of potential
side effects
perceived side effects and so on there
is also the area of sex for this
function here which can be important
then there is ethnicity that is also an
interesting interesting phenomenon
particularly in a more and more diverse
world that some some people from certain
ethnic groups and I will give you
examples later on in my talk might just
not tolerate medication because they
have different genetic variations in
their drug metabolizing enzymes for
example and so that is one other reason
another one is symptom profile and what
I mean by that is basically that there
are many ways of how people can present
when they have for example depression or
when they have schizophrenia some people
in schizophrenia hallucinate more than
others some don't solution aid at all
and so on and in depression some people
oversleep some people have seen somnium
problems so obviously you know if there
is a such a Georgina's condition it's
hard to believe that one and the same
drug will will take care of everything
it certainly it certainly makes a big
difference and you know imagine also
people may be getting depressed because
they have been traumatized for example
it's hard to believe that you know any
pill will then take care of the problem
as well you might just you know you
might just want to know about some
dramatization when you treat any
patients with depression because then
you would also
need to tackle and then start treating
dramatizations in the past so this is an
example of what I call symptom profile
or you know symptom manifestation the
type and the severity of it then last
not least we have drug drug interactions
and that particularly important because
many times many times if we add a drug
to existing drugs or the other way
around if drugs are added to you know to
our psychiatric toxic they can mean our
drug drug interactions which can
sometimes exacerbate new symptoms new
side effects and so on so the patient
comes to see you it's very important to
also rule out any drug tech interactions
and so even with all the counter
medications sent John Swartz has been
taken by many people over the counter
and supposed to alleviate depression and
it does so also but however
unfortunately it interacts with with
stroke metabolizing enzymes the SIPPs 3
or 4 one which then can cause problems
elsewhere mainly it basically can for
example make other medications
ineffective and in the UK there has been
a report that at least you know believe
it or not twenty babies or so were born
even though their mothers were on
contraception but by taking st. John's
worse against depression which is again
natural medicine the contraceptives were
not working any longer and therefore
these these mothers became pregnant so
if you wish this side-effect here could
be to have a newborn and it's not mentor
on eclis or something but it tells you
about the importance of also checking
for drug interactions including
over-the-counter medications and finally
genetic variation we're convinced such
an aggregation is going to tell us a lot
about this variability that we do see in
in the response to medication that's why
we're doing this research
we I mean as a group as a filled-in in
genetic research and it's an increasing
accreting the number of researchers and
answering publications and larger
projects which are now developing and so
on throughout the globe because yes it
is very promising it's a very promising
approach and can ultimately help many
people and save a lot of money coming
back to science if you look at the
publications that are out there
we can typically distinguish three types
of studies so in order to go and to take
you through the studies of
pharmacogenetics in psychiatry perhaps
it is important to also goes through
those three domains as they are
typically published and the first domain
are the so-called drug metabolizing
enzymes where studies are conducted in
genes which are known to either affect
absorption distribution metabolism or
excretion of certain drugs and those
genes show variation considerable
variations at times and so here we have
a good reason also to believe that we
would expect good results from such
studies then of course there is the
alternative is to look at your patients
how they respond on a certain medication
and then you do a genetic test
afterwards and examine which variations
which the corrugations were associated
with a certain outcome mainly
improvement and maybe which symptoms and
so on here the problem is a little bit
that sometimes however response to
treatment remains a bit difficult to
measure starting because you know
already starting from the problem that
people have different symptoms so they
can also improve in some different
symptoms so we have a lot of variation
here
and that that makes it sometimes
difficult to really good do a good you
know have a good judgment on how
effective drugs have been in certain
areas where those others so there can be
confounders here and therefore these
studies are a bit more a bit more if you
wish difficult to manage and to
interpret whereas with drug metabolizing
enzymes we can often measure drug levels
very precisely and that would help us
for example to understand the impact of
genetic variation finally we do have a
third category which are side effects
and here often enough we have the
chances also to be very precise and
measuring the type of side effects for
example weight gain and used by
psychotic medications and therefore you
know this can be another independent
distinguished category to conduct
studies so that is what what the field
is about in terms of studies and now
here this is a little bit of
pharmacology basics pharmacology you can
see left Chronicle kinetics and right
pharmacodynamics and basically every
time we take a pill or a drug it goes
through our intestine it goes through
our blood system and so on before it
reaches the target organ which in our
case is the brain and while it passes
basically the intestines the kidneys the
blood and so on the body is typically
working against elimination or cracking
down metabolizing the medication and
that's what that's called
pharmacokinetics basically what the body
does to the drug at the target organ in
our case mostly the brain this is called
pharmacodynamics basically what what the
medication then does to the body and we
can imagine that because these are two
very different compartments as the
pharmacologist would say we can imagine
that we can also you know use these
distinctions in our pharmacogenetic
studies which in fact we do
and we can say already at this point of
time not as a spoiler maybe but that you
know pharmacokinetics has really shown
to to be largely determined by genetic
variation which we can at this point
also measure quite well so you're going
to hear more about pharmacokinetics now
and because this is really where most of
the studies have been conducted with
most promising results going deeper into
details or drilling it a bit further
what are these drug metabolizing enzymes
well there are many of them but I think
that this one this this pie chart here
gives you an idea about the relevance of
certain drug metabolizing enzymes for
example you can see here on the Left sip
26 as a huge proportion which means in
this case the pie chart reads like
simply fix is is much involved in in
many of the psychiatric medications
it is however this you know if you could
have now imagine a you know another
tight pie chart in your mind
it is however only present to a minor
fraction in the liver therefore it can
run out of capacity quite quickly if you
overload if you all your sip 36 system
so that's why we say it has no capacity
but it also has high affinity which
means medications which are meet up
which are primarily metabolized
specifically six they have to get
metabolized by that enzyme they cannot
they cannot get metabolize elsewhere and
therefore we have a bottleneck situation
you very much with the city six so it's
a very critical
gene we will keep in mind for now then
those other ones set to see 19 for
example say three or four are equally
important but the situation might be a
bit more different here six three four
is much much more abundant so it's much
more difficult to for example you know
cause problems here but subdue c19 is
another example of a gene where we see
much you know
significant amount of variation and also
a significant amount of medications
being metabolized so this gives you an
idea about the enzymes were looking at
and I definitely like to give you an
example about in our case report I like
to do this because it tells you really
the importance of one single enzyme and
how it can really determine you know
determine very critical situations or
can be involved in actually life and
death because this is unfortunately a
you know patient back in the 1990's he
was a 36 year old male was depression he
was she was eventually he eventually
lost his job he went into a marital
breakup and he was first treated with I
mean trip tooling but then the doctor
decided to add a new medication at that
time prozac or fluoxetine on top of that
and six weeks later this this patient
was found dead in his apartment and they
measured their you know the measures of
blood concentration of drugs and they
found an excessive level from a trip to
lean and that was then speculated by by
the coroner that that would be that
would have caused the death and that
this was done intentionally and
therefore the cause of death was
determined as being suicide which in
depression unfortunately is not unusual
particularly if you have further
existing stressors like losing your job
losing your spouse and so on however the
life insurance now wouldn't pay anything
and the ex-wife therefore requested
further analysis being convinced that
this ex husband of hers would not commit
suicide without even leaving a note or
anything and luckily she found someone
who looked into it in details and
and so the presscon was involved the
author of this case reports who could in
fact show that it this intoxication has
happened because the second medication
for oxy teen has inhibited the SIP 2d6
system it has basically if you wish
you know overwhelmed the SIP to d6
system to the point that amitriptyline
which is also metabolized or simply six
could no longer be properly metabolized
and therefore it cumulative over time
and over four to six weeks it was in
fact calculated that you would reach
levels which are highly toxic which
typically ended cardiac arrest so in
this case here because of this of the
second drug
it was now a drug drug interaction it
was basically an accidental overdose in
and when fortunately was left with
consequences however the point here is
obviously that it would it wouldn't have
been detected first at all if ii look
wouldn't have been taken but the point
is that you can see that this enzyme
alone can cause a lot of issues if you
you know if you're if it's not running
it more if you don't allow or if you
have any sees and anything in your
system which which makes is sep 26 not
working well and interestingly now there
are people who are born actually about
five percent or so five to ten percent
among european patients at least who are
born with no sit to the six activity so
basically this f if they would take
fluoxetine faint since birth and we call
them the poor metabolizers in the
traditionally we can also call them no
metabolize as if you wish and this is
shown here in this graph this is a graph
of and rag addict and it's important and
rag addict is a colleague from Kansas
City who is basically devoted her
lifetime research to that enzyme alone
and she has brilliantly shown many times
how genes can or genetic variations of
that gene can influence expression and
so by the means of the current current
classification of metabolizer status we
have rapid metabolizers on the left the
normal metabolizers in the middle we
have slow metabolizers with some
impaired metabolizer system and then we
have these poor metabolizers on the
right who basically do not have any sep
26 activities based on genetic
variations basically genetic variations
over time and and and you know you can
see two things here basically most
people have a normal functioning chip 36
system so that's good news most of the
time if people will get a medication
primarily metabolize specifically 6
they will not encounter any problems so
evidence-based medicine at this point
could say well most people do well if we
have hundred patients you know at least
80% or so 75 maybe will do well so
evidence-based medicine is going to tell
you you can use this track and just be
careful not everyone will benefit maybe
however the vast majority will now
personalized medicine and using genetic
information however will allow us to
preemptively screen for those people who
are my who might get in trouble and
that's the difference between jewish
evidence-based medicine and precision
medicine because genetic variation can
very nicely at this point of time
distinguish and identify people who are
outliers particularly at the far left
and at the far right as in this case and
by doing so you can avoid a lot of
travels you can imagine and i'm going to
give an example of how much importance
this these reticle other statuses can be
for example in this medication here this
paroxetine is one of the first so-called
SSRI antidepressants and you can now see
here
sorry you can now see here that if you
are a rapid metabolizers if you have a
system which works extremely well
because you have copies actually of your
SEP 26 genes so you have copies for
whatever reason your body has as it has
created copies over SEP 26 some sometime
in in history and and you're just
inheriting it now from your parents and
so on then you can see that you can
extremely efficiently metabolize
paroxetine here at the bottom you almost
do not get any therapeutic level even if
you take a higher dose of paroxetine 40
milligrams
now the extensive metabolizers or the
normal table does are those in green
here and they typically reach a
therapeutic level at 40 milligrams
however intermediate and poor
metabolizers now can be in problem it
can be in big problems because they will
achieve much higher levels which can be
toxic for them so if you if you if you
dose someone with a sep 26 for whatever
the genetic Constitution it can cause
problems they will probably have side
effects and this tells us importance
again about this enzyme alone I would
however also emphasize that there is a
lot of ethnic variation for these step
36 metabolizer status so I've shown you
that about five to ten percent of the
Europeans are here on the right are
proved metabolizers in red but there is
about 20% of East Asians were who are
so-called you know intermediate
metabolizers but what it means is they
have a you know slightly impaired ship
to subdue c19 system and sorry sit sit
36 and and that means that they can
basically like they can also show more
likely issues at normal doses of
medications right and then interestingly
about in some areas in Africa they found
forty percent of
Africans being rapid metabolizers for
2d6 that likely has also probably had
evolutionary advantages you can imagine
that sep 26 has not been created by
nature to metabolize antidepressants but
you can well imagine that SEP 26 has
basically evolved as a way of
detoxifying Venom's
or detoxifying anything which is toxic
to your body and if you now are more
exposed to certain Venom's or maybe it
could be fruits or whatever where do you
have toxic products having a very
efficient SEP 26 system has probably
shown to be of benefits and therefore
these this in this particular area it
there has been selective pressure to
towards a 36 rapid metabolizers status
and now 40% have these these rapid
metabolizers status and as you can
imagine from the slide that I showed you
before that you will then see much less
effects if you treat someone for example
with paroxetine until you might know
that someone is a reputable either you
might just never get into therapeutic
plasma levels and that's very much true
also and that has been shown much of the
times and then finally for example for
Super Tuesday 9 teen just to just to
mention that briefly there is also a big
difference between poor metabolizers
which are much much more common in
Asians than Europeans so again here
medications which metabolize Pacifica CA
19 will much more likely be problematic
for Asians East Asians and for Europeans
okay and this just gives you basically
another idea
you see these pie charts have very
different colors and what it means is
this is again about the SIPP 2d6 system
in in different areas of the you know
different ethnic groups and basically
you can see by the by the you know
without going here too much of the
details but you can see that the colors
are different which means that certain
genic genetic variations are much more
likely or unlikely to occur
depending on your ethnic background so
it is it is a complex very complex gene
because you also have to now take into
consideration these variations when you
interpret studies and recommendations
just to keep in mind so now what our
experts saying expert groups who are you
know evaluating these these genes and
these genes variants and medications and
typically they these groups these
reviews that are written on
pharmacogenetics in psychiatry will
typically look at three things
analytical validity clinical validity
and clinical utility just to mention
them and analytic validity is basically
really you know do you have the proper
tools in hand to measure genetic
variation and to and to understand you
know the complexities of a gene and yes
you know I guess we have a very good
understanding of genes and we have very
good labs who can also do that however
we're still we're still in research
research Esther progressing to better
understand the function of these genes
variants on the gene itself and how they
interact which is out with each other
then we have clinical validity which
basically is really can a gene variant
be associated with a certain outcome yes
or no and and that is of course a
question we all want to know you know
does it really matter if you wish and
ultimately clinical utility addresses
things like is it really ready for the
clinic can you really now go and and and
should you go and offer genetic testing
for example for everyone because you
have other factors you're involved as
well for example economy is it is it is
it already clear that by testing
everyone who comes into your hospital
that you will at the end also save money
for example right and so on so these are
questions which are also addressed but
sometimes with varying decrease among
expert groups now I've been working and
it's been a big pleasure over the years
to work with the clinical
pharmacogenomics implementation
consortium and which is one of these
expert groups which basically go through
the whole entire field of medicine
not just psychiatry and our evaluating
constantly which which gene drug pairs
are actionable which means there are
enough research are there enough data to
pick up a gene and and and and and see
how it relates to certain outcomes to to
any kind of drugs but including all
subsequent relax and the clinical
pharmacogenomics implementation
consortium is independent of any I would
say pharmaceutical companies or biotech
companies or so on and they use
criterias quality criteria from the
Institute of Medicine which are listed
here which is basically the top stand
that you can have if you really want to
evaluate objectively the impact of
certain certain gene variants or
pharmacogenetics in general and so they
have started to to do this now for for
many years and and again we've been
looking at some of the most important
action or dream drug pairs in psychiatry
together and here is an example of how
our recommendation would look like so
this is a paper that looked at the
effects of sip 2d6 except to see 19
you've heard about and dosing of
tricyclic antidepressants so first
generation if you wish of
antidepressants are called tricyclics
and as you can see here on the left you
can see that the metabolizer status is
listed in four categories and on the
right you can see the level of
recommendations which was felt to be
strong which was maximum highest label
you could get so basically saying that
yes if you do know your genetic
Constitution if you do know your
metabolize the status which is you know
either one of the four and do you do
something about it or are you are we
recommending to do something about it in
the clinical setting and the
recommendation was was strong in three
out of four which means yes it we would
highly recommend to consider that
genotype Constitution that
predisposition if you want whenever you
now go and
use and prescribe tricyclics NGO
presence so very convincing arguments in
terms of the science behind that
recommendations and currently we have
published again over the past years we
have published three reviews which
looked at tricyclics antidepressants
again to the six and to see nineteen
there was another one on SSRIs which are
the new newer antidepressants like
citalopram widely prescribed sertraline
widely prescribed but also paroxetine
fluoxetine and so on again with 2d6 2019
and another one which is Karamazov in um
originally originally developed as anti
epileptic but has been shown to also
have beneficial effects for bipolar
disorder for example but also for some
pain conditions and so karma happen
however can have a very very severe side
effect called stevens-johnson syndrome
which has mostly been observed with east
asians and it has been shown that these
east asians have a certain gene
variation which is called HLA 1502
and so in some countries in some areas
in east asia now before carbamazepine is
prescribed it is mandatory now to look
at this at this gene variations and that
again has been reviewed by our Civic
team and you can even find this this
these recommendations in the
publication's in progress or in
consideration at this moment is
atomoxetine which is an ADHD drug and
again sep 26 the classes of SNR is
another class of antidepressants again
with the 36 sub-17 is being considered
and if psychotics also do have often 56
at their primary metabolizing enzyme so
it would also be interesting to look
into that and finally there's a gene and
the in the blood-brain barrier called
ABC b1 which transports or is it's a
netflix protein
which basically in which basically
regulates the concentration of certain
drugs including antidepressants and some
I'm psychotics in the brain tissue and
that is another another probably
external gene drug pair that should be
considered to for further review and and
evidence evidence-based reviewing by
experts okay what does the FDA say now
we have heard about the importance of
these genes and you know what would the
FDA for example say and I've listed here
what the FDA was currently say for
example 436 poor metabolizers in
antidepressants or for antidepressants
on the left and you can see that for all
these drugs here all these medications
these are all engine presence also
relatively widely used some some of them
where they say well wait if you do if
you if you're not a normal metabolizer
for city six you might get into problems
you might want to adjust those you might
want to take something else and so on
but you can see the list is quite long
so the FDA is actually already
recommending if you know your genotypes
they say basically if you know this then
you know you should do something about
it they don't say you should get tested
that's not the point they don't say
where are you getting get tested that
that's a different story but they
basically tell you if you know it you
should do something about it they list
also six antipsychotics where it should
be you know where it would matter and a
few other medications like
psychostimulant modafinil and so on
where you know you you would have strong
recommendations potentially to change
your plan if you knew your genotype
right and someone has now sorry and
sometimes I do say that if you are a
poor metabolizer
you should really use this as a very
critical clinical information it should
be basically labeled in in medical
reports to stop some reason what not as
almost like as if you had an allergy
let's say you know you would you would
recommend this information to be to be
propagated in your medical records
so that future my future caregivers will
be a will be aware and can do something
about it once you got tested the good
thing is we want to get tested once you
know that you're a poor metabolizer you
know it for the rest of your life so
it's a one-time-only test you need to do
in order to protect you against a lot of
medication that you might encounter
throughout your lifetime so it looks
like it would be a reasonable thing to
know your septa t6 metal at the status
and if it's not normal to actually you
know label and flag flag at any time
you're prescribed any any sort of
medications so if someone has now done a
nice job here this is shot both Bausman
subbasements paper in lens of psychiatry
and which which is really nice to read
because it has it has shown a little bit
also what is out there in terms of
opportunities to get tested which you
know which companies would typically be
around and offer this kind of testing
but also shows that you know companies
tend to include many genes sometimes in
the tests where the evidence level is
not as good as for sip 26 and subdues 19
which you can see on the left bottom
here you know you can see they're about
six seven or eight genes where the
evidence is really strong and then with
with you know going down the the
evidence becomes lower and lower and
lower but you know companies might still
feel inclined to also add those genetic
tests but all of them typically do
include sip to the six in step to see 19
which is shown on the right graph on the
upper half you can see that 100% of the
companies oh inclusive to the six up to
see 19 because that's really where I
guess you know most of the evidence if
is out there however we still you know
we still see a lot of things going on
here in this area in the
commercialization of genetic tests and
still however
you know I would very much advocate to
look into you know solely comprehensive
written reviews because unfortunately
what happens is that sometimes if tests
are being offered and they are you know
based on you know where some genes are
based on on poor evidence people tend to
brush away the whole test and think that
the whole the whole test isn't working
or is not it's not ready yet and and
this negatively affects the field of
genetic testing for those genes where it
would be actually really important as
and as I showed you 26 and to see 19
would be among the would be good results
among them and maybe HLA also for Asians
and here we have again we need to really
encourage everyone who works in
pharmacogenetics and who is making
statements towards a clinical
application to really choose among the
good reviews and and those who are
really um you know based on on science
and data again like sub such as C pick
reviews or something like that in order
to make proper conclusions okay and last
at last half of the talk you basically
I'm going to tell you briefly a little
bit about of what we've been doing at
CAMH
here in Toronto because we have been
feeling that it would actually be
important to provide genetic testing to
our patients and did that starting in
2009 when really no one else except one
or two clinics such as the Mayo Clinic
in the US for example which would have
started to do this genetic testing to
improve treatment and we started in 2009
with a study which is listed here
briefly and this is a flowchart of the
study we have encouraged every patient
who was treated here to be enrolled in
our study and would then follow up the
results of the genetic testing with with
them and
positions and would then also want to
know first of all if it's you know if
it's a feasible thing to do if it's
exact if it's accepted if there are
maybe misunderstandings potentially in
terms of what these tests can do and so
we had developed a questionnaire called
the pip FQ which was our outcome measure
here to see about general to understand
outcomes and attitudes also later just
to give you an idea later we have had
the so-called impact study starting 2012
where we have also expanded our genetic
testing profile done more research and
we have now through the through our
hospitals and other hospitals and other
community centers enrolled more than
10,000 patient at the mean in the
meantime 10,000 patient genotypes where
we have data on their outcome of
medication where we have data on their
genetic variation and so on so it's
going to be really exciting to analyze
all this data and we just recently
published the whole study protocol if
you're interested anyway this is just
what we're doing here in order to you
know move forward with the
implementation of that sort of genetic
testing and we have then also
collaborated with with a company who has
used a combinatorial approach which
means that you know drugs are certainly
targeting multiple targets and receptors
and transmitters and whatnot and they're
metabolized also by many different genes
and and the ultimate ultimate best test
was certainly some tests where you would
in incorporate like in an algorithm all
the possible combinations of genetic
variations and then basically come up
with a plan and the plan could be for
example tube in your medications into
three categories yes you can use them as
directed or you should be more cautious
or you should better avoid it but if you
still want to do this you know just make
sure that you might do a bit more
frequent monitoring for example and just
to just to be clear on this and no
genetic testing is meant to replace
common sense judgment of any physician
and even if you feel inclined to give a
medication where where the genetic test
might warn you about it still it's still
ultimately at the physicians decisions
and discretion and what they want to
discuss and what they what they feel
would be best to the patients so it
shouldn't be replacing it's not it's an
aim to replace any any any treatment
algorithm or protocols that are out
there it should rather be used as
additional information as additional
information to optimize your treatment
and and again this this is one way of
doing it or certainly more than more
than this one here but however
ultimately this is what we all want this
is what we would all be hoping to have a
tool which takes into consideration
various genes and also incorporates
their interactions and for example your
simplistic poor metabolizer
and fit to see 19 poor metabolizer now
you really have probably a problem with
medications more much more likely which
are metabolized by these two enzymes
right so you want to just know about
that and you want to also know what you
do in certain combinations so that's the
way to go and that's a study we're
currently conducting but I'm going to
show you here now just to give you an
idea this 382 physicians who have filled
out the question is about how they liked
our medication sorry other height or
genetic testing at whenever the
prescribed new medications to their
patients and I'm going to show you here
briefly the results this question was if
you were given treatment recommendations
and have taken this into consideration
would you say that compared to baseline
your patient has benefited from the
treatment changes the idea was you know
we don't want to harm we don't want to
cause harm to patients so the idea was
if we do include genetic information and
now you know patients have been treated
would we would we see that you know
there it might it might actually
have caused basis to complain for
example or physicians to say no it
didn't work and and you know we may have
over you know also creating perhaps
false expectations was our worry here so
first at all as a physician you always
do not want to harm anyone this is
premium meal not Zura and the results
were surprising and so in certain ways
that you know we can see that basically
these are the outcomes
anytime we gave genetic information and
patients were assessed for a second time
or as for a third time later on by the
same physician most most likely was a
predominance of under twenty two two two
times patients improved and no one or my
only two reported to get minimally worse
obviously this is great because it shows
there was apparently no harm done which
was our first goal and to know to
understand what happens if you use some
exact testing now is it a proof that
pharmacokinetics is superior to
treatment as usual no that's not the
proof here but at least it shows again
that you're unlikely to harm anyone in
this cone in this situation and this is
what I'm saying here so far so good but
however we would need a different sort
of study to evaluate the superiority of
treatment and that's where we started
our RCT randomized clinical control
trial which is called the gap study and
this is an ongoing study where we are
having patients or with depression
patients with schizophrenia and they are
read they are prospectively assessed
once we have genetic testing completed
and given the recommendations to fate to
physicians and once where the physicians
could just choose and we're blind to the
genotypes
which we call treatment as usual and
that will be compared after twelve weeks
of treatment and long-term pull ups are
also included cost-benefit analysis will
be added and so on and this should also
then hopefully show us the superiority
and to which extent genetic driven
treatment is better than treatments
usual we have then also included markers
for X according this weight gain that we
have developed here in Toronto and the
we have identified the electrons I
should say and also want to know whether
or not using these markers for NF
psychotic induced weight gain
I can also you know be beneficial in
treatment up front good so with that I
conclude the first large part of
pharmacokinetics and we'll use the last
minute to briefly take you through the
two other remaining domains one of which
is symptom reduction therapeutic
response as we've said and here we have
liver recently more recently started to
conduct some research in late life
depression this is characterized by
depression after age of 60 65 typically
and this is another somewhat challenging
condition to treat sometimes because
there are more comorbidities now in the
elderly
morkul medications the more susceptible
to side effects many times so here we
also believe that if we could improve
treatment by using genetics we can we
can largely expect benefits and also it
should be noted that depression is a
risk factor for Alzheimer disease and
therefore treating depression adequately
and appropriately and efficiently will
also delay or even prevent perhaps onset
of Alzheimer disease in many patients so
that is the breakdown of the study it's
a very very nice study sample 350
subjects were treated first 12 weeks
with venlafaxine and I was really
determined afterwards if there are
responders or not and if there were not
responders they were moved on to placebo
or a belief augmentation but the point
is here that we clearly had a very good
understanding of these bases were
responding on venlafaxine or not
and so here is a breakdown of the
response curves and you can clearly see
that the blue line means you know on
average patients this this group of
patients as cluster of patient has not
responded very well as mostly remained
more or less in the same symptom
severity score and you can see two other
clusters I would say even though you can
almost group them but which which have
shown either you know faster response at
the beginning but then then a less less
you know less sustained progress later
on or people who have first not not
shown much improvement in the first one
of the weeks but then have a sustained
and actually optimal way of responding
and alleviating the symptoms and now we
looked at a very obvious candidate which
is the norepinephrine transporter gene
because the norepinephrine transporter
gene the enzyme is blocked by this
medication benefaction is blocking
norepinephrine transport within the
synaptic cleft and we can nicely see
that this variation was was nicely
associated with outcome to treatment and
if you look at the orange line these are
those people who have responded much
better to enough vaccine and they had a
genotype which actually affected the
expression of the norepinephrine
transporter and that is a nice study I
think a nice evidence that or suggestive
evidence and so for the replicated
perhaps but that you know that this gene
might play a role in late life
depression if you treat patients with an
S and arrive and that can be used to
pulley in the future to you know an
added in genetic testing modules to
improve treatment
last but least now the last minutes is
going to be able to side-effects and
I've been particularly involved in in
studying weight gain weight gain because
bacon is a very severe can be a very
severe side effects with particularly -
antipsychotic medications which are
listed here on the Left clozapine and
olanzapine cause on average and adults
after 12 weeks 4 to 5 kilograms of
weight and that is that is substantial a
substantial amount and keep in mind that
some people might not gain weight
perhaps even but some people do now
again probably even double or triple the
amount of weight in this time so there's
a huge variation and unfortunately
however why don't we just then pick
lowest risk medications and it's being
done this is why rizal on the right here
is one of the most prescribed denim
psychotics at this moment because it has
a much lower propensity to to induce
weight gain and is otherwise well
tolerated also unfortunately when
conditions are more severe more chronic
and treat and resistant
clozapine remains still the NF psychotic
the state of art for treatment-resistant
schizophrenia so the problem is we just
cannot avoid using it and probably 10
percent of patients on schizophrenia are
taking clozapine and are benefitting
tremendously about this unfortunately
however some of them gain a lot of
weight I would like to understand more
about the mechanism to avoid it so we've
done a series of studies in the past
we've looked at various gene pathways
and this is just a list of genes we
found in our list of genes where we
found an interesting association with NF
s economies weight gain to be followed
up and also to be evaluated but there's
one gene here which I believe is
particularly interesting and that's the
mineral coding for receptor gene
recording for receptor is involved in
satiety and appetite regulation and
there is a gene variant which was also
so she was obesity in general population
and it looks like that that that same
variant or at least a variant witches in
linkage disequilibrium which is
by and and does also affect an
expression if you wish it's very much
involved in in risk for weight gain
which which you can see here on these
four samples and each time in in each of
these four samples across the world it
was shown that also have this a a
genotype are at much higher risk to to
significantly gain weight and that
certainly certainly is a good you know a
study result because you see the
replications in in different areas with
different medications in different
patients and hopefully this this you
know gene can be further validated and
then included in a risk in a genetic
risk panel like this one here which is
again a very preliminary study but based
on our study sample if we included these
six genes into one panel and we would
test all these six genes preemptively
before getting treatment we could nicely
distinguish people who have low risk
genes where or no restream variants they
would even on average tend to lose some
weight but those who have more at least
two or three or four risk variants would
gain weight and also at five six or
seven of these gene variants they would
actually gain a lot of weight at least
10% or more and so that's where we are
hoping to go to building a multi gene
tests also for side effects which can be
used independently of any of the other
tests for example zip to the six tests
and so on or in conjunction I am at some
point but this is hopefully we're going
to so last at least then I would like to
summarize and I guess you've all seen
and understood the current current
situation for the fats it's so-called
phase one sip enzymes and how much the
influence rock levels response and side
effects
with many psychotic and psychotropic
antidepressants antipsychotics
you've been shown that or you know I
guess you get an understanding that the
implementation is slowly progressing and
it's more and more adopted globally
genetic test might become available
however also specifically to predict
side-effects excuse me and this is the
group here in Toronto I'm most closely
working with and I would like to thank
them because obviously a lot of work
here being done and and we are you know
we're basically having um having a great
team here and a great infrastructure to
to do many of these science research
tests but also in terms of clinical
application and implementation so with
that I would like to stop my
presentation thank you so much for your
attention and please let me know if you
have any questions thank you
Thank You dr. Mueller for that
informative presentation we will not
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button
what answer as many of your questions as
we have time for okay let's get started
our first question is do you think
PGX is ready for clinical application
yeah PGX EV is its abbreviation for
pharmacogenetics and as you can see or
as you have heard it is it is now
recommended to use whenever you know
your genotyping information and you are
now expected to be treated with
medications which means once you know
them means obviously once you have
undergone some way of genetic testing
the question really is would you like to
do it would you not like to know it your
genotypes and here we see that the
majority of patients is clearly in favor
of conducting genetic testing whenever
they know that they need to take a
medication the question really remains
however who's going to pay for this and
and how is information be delivered and
I believe that coming coming to coming
to concluded I would think that yes it
is ready for clinical application as
long as you do it properly as long as
you have access to a good lab and as
long as you can you can certainly also
cover the cost somewhere then it
shouldn't be a problem now if you want
to however be on the more let's say
reasonable economical side you can now
decide to for example you know give
first everyone a chance to respond on a
standard antidepressant which which
might be safe to
five for example sertraline because it
does not you know it is not so much
metabolized by these two drug enzymes
but if it doesn't work out and you now
have to give a second medication in
maybe half of your patients that you
treat it then a genetic test should much
more be considered at this point of time
because now you want to really probably
look into more details and also would
benefit from an information
okay where should people get tested yeah
that's an excellent question and
basically it really very much depends on
which which clinic you might be going to
do they already offer genetic testing
and there are more and more clinics who
do so but perhaps before you get into
treatment you may want to find out
whether or not there is a clinic in your
city which does you know provide genetic
testing as part of your treatment plan
you may want otherwise look up the
internet you may want to perhaps also
have a discussion with your insurance
company if they would reimburse it
because some insurance companies do
reimburse testing and they might have
collaborations with certain partners and
then you could you could you know you
could follow their advices and certainly
you know you're free to meet with your
physician and discuss it with them and
they might know ways of how and where to
do it
and ultimately you can also collaborate
with a physician and you can also
suggest them to help you get the genetic
testing done because in many times
companies will like to have and report
results to their to a physician rather
than to patients directly um and
therefore you know you should you should
perhaps speak to a physician and see
what what what they know you should you
should do some research find clinics in
your city talk to insurance companies
and so on and ultimately that would that
would you know you should you should be
able to find to find a good a good plan
and again there is research publications
who also list centers otherwise feel
free to connect with researcher like me
and you know we're happy to - you know -
to assist and and hopefully can can find
can can find some some ways of where you
could ideally find your genetic testing
lab
okay we have time for one more question
what jeans should they look at another
excellent question and I think that we
have heard in my talk here that at this
point of time if you really go by
conservative means if you really you
know follow signs and research data that
there is two enzymes for drug
metabolizing purposes you want to know
for sure
this is 2 D 6 and 2 C 19 then you may
want to consider HLA in case you know
you have you know in case you might be
an Asian and you are potentially looking
into car massive in treatment these are
the these are I would think and the most
conservative standards the genes you
should absolutely look at and and and at
this point of time the best evidence is
for these two genes with psychiatric
medications the other ones are not
necessarily unusual useless other ones
that that can include other sip enzymes
and so on but again the level is lower
and the information the actionable
actionable information might be just
less and might be more basically a bit
more experimental at this point of time
but it is important of course to to
conduct research and to also you know
find the right balance between between a
standardized treatment and and I mean
bike where you have a good evidence plus
combining it with with genes which are
still more on an investigation order to
allow also for more research and for a
better understanding for that in the
future
we can expand the gene lists much much
more and much better confidence and much
better evidence yeah
all right I would like to once again
thank dr. Mueller for his presentation
but also like to thank laberd's for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's broadcast
will be available on-demand viewing
through September of 2018 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay we share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us we hope to see you again soon goodbye